quelle personnalité va par théo va
participer au règne du shopping dans une
émission spéciale petit à 10 elle ne
sait vraiment plus où aller
kelly valérie damidot non
non non non non elle a fait des
révélations étonnantes hier sur france 2
venant au projet une bâche aux bravo il
faut prendre l'accent qu'élire l'accent
ch'ti m'a bien entendu donc voila et
venance aussi abattu près l'action
c'est vrai pour la prochaine fois et oui
roselyne bachelot je vous dis elle a
fait une révélation hier dans les rênes
du shopping sur m6 à nous dire ce que
vous en pensez qu'à rapidement regardé
c'était qu'elle rocqué sur france 2 dans
les enfants de la terre 6 décidément
roselyne bachelot fait beaucoup parler
d'elle ces dernières semaines après
avoir fait le buzz pendant la période de
confinement suite à la réapparition
d'une archive dans laquelle elle parlait
des stocks de masques en france c'est
aujourd'hui avec une révélation pour le
moins surprenante que l'ancien ministre
de la santé fait l'actu après avoir été
femmes politiques chroniqueuse et
animatrice
roselyne bachelot va devenir candidate
d'une émission de télé c'est sur france
2 qu'elle a révélé qu'elle sera l'une
des invités des reines du shopping de
cristina cordula ça va être diffusé
c'est vrai que côté look rose layette au
top
admirez cette veste des plus magnifiques
sa magnifique une émission à découvrir
prochainement sur m6 non la belle vous
jure je me demande s'il n'y a pas
quelque chose qui n'est pas du tout en
fait robben boulloche mettant des signes
c'est un compliment mais alors oui alors
oui c'est ce qui se passe alors se poser
une bâche le oui elle va faire les rênes
du shopping comme invité oui mais alors
que vous en pensez mais moi si vous êtes
aussi bonne au tennis parce que déjà
elle fait ça pour une oeuvre caritative
par rapport justement à l'alzheimer
en plus nous on l'a connu dans les pieds
dans le plat grâce à vous et c'est vrai
que c'est une icône de mode
elle adore ça elle va voir les défilés
de haute couture elle avait toujours des
looks absolument incroyable moi je
trouve quand même plutôt pas mal
après après roselyne bachelot c'est vrai
que j'aime bien mais surtout en couture
ce cas la plus plus fréquent c'est
qu'elle retourne beaucoup sa veste un
voile assez heureuse ah oui moi je suis
d'accord c'est bien qu'elle le fasse
pour une association caritative etc
néanmoins je peux pas m'empêcher de
penser que elle y va aussi parce qu'elle
adore aller sur les plateaux de la
bourse
peu importe le sait son kif et moi je la
préfère quand elle est en expert qu
entre guillemets ex politique nous
parler des coulisses où nous décrypter
des choses on peut être d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec elle mais au moins il a
une compétence et quelque chose ou alors
dans une émission type les pieds dans le
plat parce que là on était des humides
et des gens qui quittent débattions avec
humour de voilà bien sûr avec messieurs
mais sur un truc comme ça je gens me
voient les séjours mis derrière après on
va on va passer à d'autres sujets
schultz a décrit vise même sa carrière
d'avant politique parce qu'en fait je me
rends compte qu'en fait le cal faisait
la politique c'était pour être devant
les micros pour être devant les caméras
parce qu'en fait c'est son kiff dès
qu'elle arrêtait la caméra n'a eu de
cesse que d'en chercher
comme d'habitude les micros les caméras
pour parler de tout et n'importe quoi
franchement chou c'est dommage
qu'est ce que tu fais toi en fait il
n'était pas ministre
non mais elle a décrit d'arrêter la
politique mais alors justement autre
chose et pour faire mine à mort les gens
me tue le voit pas partout il est dans
tpm pdc nous on dit qu'elle veut faire
de la télé elle dit qu'elle veut être
devant les caméras elle dit qu'elle est
devenue l aime ça elle aime cette
notoriété la pourrait même changer la
politique pour sort du banc